mr sully guys we got ourselves a second
trailer for uncharted today but what's
really important to tell y'all spectrum
is here for the last hour and a half and
i think we finally got the internet
working again
success we'll see how long this last
ladies and gentlemen was not a big fan
of that first trailer i'm hoping this
one's better it's going to start before
it's definitely going to be better
you just know it is this is how
hollywood works it's gonna be good
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
five billion easy
but it's just a story i beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
fortune
then was betrayed
i have been searching for it all in vain
both you turn your keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot you almost got me killed
clockwise sully well it was 50 50 so i
made a guess clearly
but the footage was not just about gold
it was something much more valuable this
girl has a very tragic history so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me
[Music]
don't get caught
don't get caught
me back there somebody had to get the
cross
is this feeling more like uncharted
[Music]
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
oh you know my brother said who's
playing him you have no idea who you
partnered with
what else aren't you telling me
the victor spoils
how are they going to get them out of
here
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was better that was much better put
them down boys
what is that thing on your face
puberty's right around the corner
everything is fixed
they heard their response to the last
one we got to give them something they
said cut that led zeppelin crap let's
get some actual score in here let's give
us a swashbuckling vibe but more
importantly you get that man a mustache
get this man a stash and knowing sony
that's the final scene of the movie
right yeah he shows
just in time to set up the sequel where
he has his mustache i mean some time
would have needed to have passed and it
looks like some time has passed from the
fact that he's not look it appears that
drake is on his like own little
adventure at that moment turns around
and surprised to see sully one of the
first things he says is what's that on
your face
classic classic classic uncharted
hollywood this looks increasingly fun
and passable
yes it does fun passable entertainment
it felt more like uncharted than the
last damn trail this at least seems like
it's attempting to be an uncharted
adaptation you know what i mean yeah it
still hasn't quite answered the question
as to how much uncharted there will be
versus how much like we're in the you
know like that big set piece where
they're at the party in the gala like it
looks like there's a lot that takes
place that almost feels like it would be
the first half of the movie before they
get to actually going into uncharted
territories and finding lots of
treasures being nitpicky john i think
this is so great
fans want and fun tom holland christmas
and uh hey if there's anything people
love it's tom holland and mark wahlberg
and the hollywood mathematicians can't
be wrong about that because both of them
are charming and people like them so
that must mean that they're the perfect
people to play these roles yeah it looks
okay like the whole thing would it felt
at least had this like swashbuckling
adventure a vibe about it where the the
other one
felt like
relatively small with like a random
plane sequence from uncharted 3.
like this actually feels like bigger
scope to it you know i like the
riddle solving the puzzle solving yeah
stuff that they do there
and of course like the ancient treasure
troves and like the kind of villain
antonio banderas is and this romance
with chloe i believe is her name i think
chloe comes in the second game where you
learn that they dated before the main
love interest elena comes in in the
first game okay and then she kind of is
throughout the i think that's how it
goes it's been a while wait i wanted to
see that we don't know who was playing
sam
do we did they they had a photo of him
that's sebastian stan oh that's the kid
that's when they're kids yeah so we
don't know who it is damn it i would i
would venture a guess not but maybe we
could figure out what your car feels
definitely making your garfield people
and then sully can have a long-lost
brother too and that could be played by
toby mcgregor yeah how come one have fun
with that bee sure let's do it i would
actually i would be on board for the
wild ride that would present i mean this
looks this looks entertaining the more
distance you get from the games the more
enjoyment you'll have with this which is
what every video game adaptation
here yeah man that's what you gotta hear
but if you if you squint and step back
really far you'll be excited there's
going to be a lot of people who are
going to watch this who've never touched
the video game right uh-huh so you and
you got to take it on its own merits
totally and there's gonna be people who
just watch it because they like tom
holland you know how many people watch
the eternals just because they heard
about a certain post credit scene a lot
of people a lot of a lot of people who
came out in tr
tropes a lot of times with [ __ ] like
this my mind just goes to one thing
which is all right if you're gonna like
botch everything
at least get the action right at least
make it fun at least make the action
look really appealing and really cool
while there's some
nice shots here or there some cool
looking shots i'm waiting for that thing
where i'm like oh the action looks sweet
you know like that i feel like that can
often be your saving grace sure and like
i want the action to look sweet and at
least make me laugh here's my thing with
ruben fleischer that's who's directing
this right he often has trailers for
movies that just look awful and then i
watch his films and i'm like
yeah
and i think that's the thing about his
his movies for some reason that they
don't lend themselves to the greatest
marketing this might be all right dude
it just looks okay all right what do you
think
it's a video live action video game
movie john charles started tom holland
and mark wahlberg it looks like
passively entertaining yeah not much
worry you could say right let's deep
dive into it
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button do you guys think this trailer
was better i sure hope you did it's the
best trailer sure hope you did all right
guys we'll see you soon say hi to jesus
you